à propos du Fouquette sur TF1 PPDA
s'enflammait c'est une formidable pub
pour ce restaurant qui fait hôtel depuis
peu Patrick n'est pas forcé d'évoquer sa
vie privée à l'antenne Guillon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mon petit Stéphane ça va ça va
bien
et on commence par cette initiative des
magasins Bricorama qui dès dimanche ont
salué la victoire de Nicolas Sarkozy
autre beau geste la compagnie Ryanair
offre 50 000 billets d'avion pour fêter
le nouveau président dans 15 jours la
compagnie Air France offrira 500000
billets à nos amis sans papiers
direction Bamako
une victoire ça s'arrose Nicolas a enfin
passé une nuit entière avec Cécilia un
exploit ovationné par le personnel du
Fouquet sous la forme d'une haie
d'honneur il est vraiment il est
vraiment fait nommé
tout ça pour ça
à propos du Fouquet sur TF1 PPDA
s'enflammait c'est une formidable pub
pour ce restaurant qui fait hôtel depuis
peu Patrick n'est pas forcé d'évoquer sa
vie privée à l'antenne
[Applaudissements]
un quinquennat a démarré en tronc des
dimanches une première mesure très
courageuse faire redécouvrir à la France
la chanteuse préférée de Stéphane Bern
enfin une consolation si Ségolène avait
gagné ses romans Serda qui aurait chanté
la Marseillaise on a eu chaud
parce que
Parti socialiste on sait enfin ce qui
s'est dit dimanche rue de Solférino
entre Sego et François moi aussi je veux
passer nuit au Fouquet ça te dit pas
question tu as perdu on rentre à la
maison
et puis un document rarissime le seul
sourire de DSK durant toute la campagne
c'était dimanche quand il a glissé un
bulletin Sarkozy dans l'urne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
8 mai 45 dernières commémoration pour
Jacques Chirac on s'est emmerdé dépôt
d'une gerbe accolade aux anciens
combattants l'année prochaine on fêtera
ça au Fouquet champagne à gogo [ __ ] et
karaoké
[Applaudissements]
des traces de cou sur l'un des bébés oui
il y avait deux boîtes de pizza au
fromage qui bloquaient l'entrée du
congélo donc madame courgeot a dû passer
bébé en force
[Applaudissements]
musique cette mort lors d'un concert de
la star academy tunisienne oui là-bas il
vote et après ils zigouillent les
perdants ça évite qu'il fasse un disque
deux ans plus tard Nolwenn en Tunisie ce
serait fini depuis longtemps
excuse-moi
je le pense pas c'est juste
un grand bravo journal Le Parisien pour
ce titre ils n'ont pas fait exprès je
précise mode de points une ligne pocket
[Applaudissements]
et on termine on termine avec notre jeu
de la semaine l'adieu de Bernadette
Chirac à Rostropovitch où est le
macchabée
envoyez vos réponses à la semaine
prochaine merci beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu